let's move on to the stuff that we have
with peptides as well today because
you've recently put out a book
um you've got a strong connection with a
peptide company
um that that researches and puts
together all the peptides that you know
we're going to talk about today and
again there's a link for that in the
video description that says for peptides
visit limit
limitlesslifeneutropics.com forward
slash rich and if you use the coupon
code he gave me was rich 50 and it gets
you 15 off the stuff so let's let's hop
into the peptide stuff because there's
there's a new fat loss peptides which
are relatively new to the marketplace
yeah and you first mentioned it to me a
few months ago and since you've
mentioned it I've had a lot of people
bring it up yeah
um so I'm going to pronounce it
completely wrong so I'll let you do it
I'm I'm just going to copy and paste
them in the chat here yep so you guys
have record of it if you guys want to
look them up later but go ahead yeah so
no problem um well so first off let me
just say um you know going back to Dr
Jay I'm in total agreement dude like
it's a joke I've actually told him I'm
like bro you should charge a thousand
dollars for this like why are you
charging 500 or 600 and you're right so
for 300 it's like it's a doctor though
he's not a businessman no yeah exactly I
mean but I mean it's like you're ripping
him off at 300 I mean it's the most
insane [__] you guys are gonna go back
to it bro do you still go to yours I
still look at mine
yeah like like once every three or four
months if I start taking a supplement
I'm like oh you know what I'm gonna go
back and look for this to see but anyway
go go do it he's he's 100 right and and
by the way you guys I know that there's
somebody watching this right now has
gynecomastia
um it's very important I've said this on
Richard's show many times before if
you're taking drugs to stop gyno you're
[__] killing yourself okay you have
to get it cut out don't play games get
it cut out in Canada it's probably free
I can recommend a surgeon I know like
two or three of them there know how to
do it the problem with gyno is that most
doctors don't know how to do it Richard
as you know because they just cut out
the actual tissue and then it comes back
so you have to cut out the glandular
tissue okay so that means they have to
go up in through here and pull it all
out it's not a bad deal it's an
outpatient procedure but they will have
to put a drain in for three or four days
I think most surgeries if you got to do
both nipples which most guys will have
to do you know in like the us or the
West is going to cost you five to seven
Grand it's about less money you ever
spent [__] gyno Burns it's horrible
you can't hug your kids your dog jumps
up on you're like ow you know why if you
it just sucks get it cut out anyway I'm
done with that
um so so peptides I definitely want to
say this um
and I'll mention his name but I probably
shouldn't but uh Dr Peter Atia is now
like the big name celebrity doctor right
like everybody uses him when they say
this that and the other and Richard I'm
sure you've had people that have emailed
you about this the big story right now
for The glp-1 Agonist that's so these
are the fat loss peptides that Richard
has talked about there's two main ones
and they are called scientific names or
simaglitide which is Olympic or ozympic
I can't ever pronounce that word and
then terzapatide which is the newest
glp-1 Agonist which is Manjaro now those
are the retail names of the drugs now
what's happening in the pharmaceutical
world is a lot of the Compounders are
blending these with other agents like B
vitamins and choline and carnitine and
stuff like that so that they can mollify
the pa the patent and they can sell it
to you for cheaper but at the end of the
day
I'm literally not kidding you I just
sent an email about this yesterday
these are the two most profound
fat loss agents known to man
five years ago you could not write a
book so my you don't know the switcher
button my next book coming out which is
coming out within the next two months is
going to be called 30 days to shreds and
it is going to be you know not some bro
bodybuilder get ripped in 30 days book
it's going to be literally like a
deconstruction of how Science Now allows
people to lose 15 to 25 pounds of pure
visceral body fat in 30 days or less
using these agents and
Peter attia and some other people and
it's going to continue and I'm going to
make a bigger point in this in a second
but they're talking about how these
agents are causing muscle loss in the
users and the problem and again I want
all of you guys to know this I first off
I've been using both of these agents
there's appetite's only been in the
marketplace for public use since August
of last year so maglota's been in the
marketplace since December of 2021. I
started some maglotide in January of
2022 and I started to appetite in August
of 2022. so I've used all of these drugs
for Combined more than a year but each
more than six months my wife has also
used some agletide
it's a lie what they're saying I mean
you already know Richard I mean you know
what comes out of the mainstream if it
bleeds it leads but they are measuring
muscle loss and obese more morbidly
obese you know again comorbid what they
call patient population groups because
these people are 400 pounds 375 pounds
whatever they are and the doctors are
writing them scripts for these drugs
which dramatically suppress appetite
that's the number one thing they do they
suppress your appetite terzapatite also
is a metabolic on coupler which means
that over time as you use it it enhances
BMR which is basic metabolic rate which
means you'll burn more calories at rest
so you you know me and Richard if we're
on it right now are burning more
calories at rest talking on a podcast
than the average person who's listening
okay so but but the bottom line is
if you do this right and what I mean by
right is and again you know this Richard
and most of your audience knows this too
you exercise and you lift weights you do
cardiovascular exercise right you reduce
carbohydrate intake which is essentially
living insulin controlled you get enough
sleep you do all the other things that
obviously People Like Us that are living
the quote unquote optimized lifestyle do
and you throw these agents in they're
they're gifts from the fat loss Gods I
mean these are literally Golden Age
biotech but if again you're a morbidly
obese person and your doctor says hey I
can write you a script for a zenpick or
church appetite and then you start using
it and it kills your appetite and you
stop eating well yeah you're gonna drop
weight
but as you know you're going to crash
your metabolism you're going to crash
your thyroid and so what ends up
happening is these people lose Richard
I'm telling you I've had a hundred
emails in the last three months from
people they lose a hundred pounds again
morbidly obese people they lose 100
pounds in three months and they're like
this is the greatest thing I've ever
seen in my life they come off of it and
they gain 150 pounds back in two months
and why it had they gained why did they
gain the weight back because again they
crashed their metabolism their thyroid
is completely malfunctioned they didn't
lose the weight correctly they did not
eat you know one gram per pound of lean
body mass they didn't lift weights again
they're fat people how do people get fat
they don't exercise they don't eat right
so then you give them this amazing drug
that kills their appetite and they keep
being a fat person right they just eat
less they don't do anything correctly
and the doctors don't instruct them how
to do this correctly so then yes these
people lose muscle and Peter attia and
other people that are glomming on I saw
this Dr Kyle Gillette the other day was
interviewed by Thomas delauer I know you
know Thomas I mean these guys are
literally coming on now saying they're
horrible
don't use them I saw Kyle Gillette said
that he has women that have gallbladder
issues and I'm like if you're morbidly
obese a type 2 diabetic and you take
this drug and now you're not eating
right but maybe two meals a day instead
of six you're still eating the same [__]
or
you don't get enough fiber and roughage
and greens and all these other things
and so yeah you can you're constipated
so yeah you're gonna have gallbladder
issues but this does not correlate to
healthy people which is the majority of
your audience the majority of my
listening audience so unfortunately as
you know the healthy people are now
being lied to
and they're freaking out they're like oh
my god dude I don't know my doctor said
you know he watched the interview with
Dr Peter attia that was in the mail and
he's like I don't think I should be
using him anymore I'm like well what how
do you feel on them like do you have
side effects no I'm it's the greatest
thing I've ever had I've lost all this
weight are you still lifting are you
still eating insulin control are you
doing your cardio well yeah then you're
good
um
you're the only side effect this is the
truth the only side effect for people
like us who use these drugs is smaller
bowel movements who doesn't want smaller
bowel movements I mean literally dude
when I first started doing this a year
ago I was a little bit concerned because
I'm like what's going on and then I
started looking into the the biology and
the Pharma pharmacokinetics of what
these things do and they do increase
bile salt and metabolic equations and
and biochemical Cascades to break down
the food that you're eating and then
when you combine that with the idea that
you're not eating as much anymore then
yes you're going to have smaller bowel
movements but I'm telling you they did
years of research double-blind
placebo-controlled studies on health I'm
sorry on unhealthy people type 2
diabetics which as you know are usually
human dumpster fires these are people
that treat their body like [__] and none
of them had really bad side effects but
all of them showed massive weight loss
okay so again the devil is in the
details context is key if you know how
to lose body fat correctly and again I
don't have to get into it but it's you
know protein enough protein per pound of
lean body mass resistance training
cardiovascular training proper sleep you
know reducing your carbohydrate intake
this is the greatest thing that you
could ever use because nothing
will lose or drop body fat as fast as
these drugs will and and dude you know
about fasting I don't have to get into
fasting if you're a faster these are the
greatest tools ever
because now you have no hunger pangs you
know you don't get the 16 17 18 hours
and you're like oh bro I gotta [__]
eat you don't have hunger do you still
get like all the benefits of fasting if
you use these appetite suppressants like
the ketones and all that stuff after a
certain period of time or does it
suppress it so that's a great question a
hundred percent you do so all these
things so the autophagy and all that
still happens exactly so I I was just
dude we're so connected you literally
just stole my thunder I was gonna say
because I don't fast that often like if
I do I find it painful it's like this
sucks like so bro you will literally be
able to fast on these no I was that's
where I was going so both of these drugs
and by the way let me just decline this
a little bit so somagotide is older uh
it's been around longer it's been
studied more more people are using it
because again availability it turns
appetite like I said just came out in
August of last year but ter's appetite
is five to ten times better than some
agletide because it's more tolerated uh
and again because it's a metabolic
uncoupler where some aglotide isn't now
I don't want to confuse people and you
know me I can send a lot of information
out but there's actually one coming that
Limitless is going to have
hopefully again quotes uh within the
next month to a month and a half that is
a triple Agonist which actually means
okay so some magnetite is a single
Agonist there's appetite is a double
Agonist and the triple Agonist will mean
it attacks fat loss from all three
Pathways so the pathways of fat loss are
caloric restriction or you know appetite
suppression metabolic and coupling
enhanced thermogenesis and then the the
final aspect is
um accelerated caloric burning when
you're exercising so imagine when you
exercise you have like another blast
furnace going on now
um enhancing caloric burn while you
exercise so that so there literally is
one coming that you can use and not take
anything else other than maybe
testosterone in a growth hormone peptide
or growth GH itself and you will be
completely and totally shredded if you
live the lifestyle seriously and it's
it's been it's uh it's already been
through phase two clinical trials I have
some questions for you sure
um so a good friend of mine is taking
turns appetite what was the brand name
um
Manjaro that's it so that's the one that
he got
um we were talking on my on my General's
uh conversation I don't know like a
month ago maybe six weeks ago when he
first started it and he's like yeah I'm
gonna do this I've heard this this that
and the other thing so I sent a text to
my uh trainer and I asked him if he had
any experience with teres appetite so
this is what he said so I'm just going
to read it back to you because he didn't
he didn't really like the idea so I want
to hear how you feed back to me says not
available in Canada as far as I can tell
it's still purpose antibiabetic drug
that started as a glp-1 Agonist known as
Victoza I use Victor's in 2014 and lost
30 pounds and stopped put about 60
people on it since this is promising but
I don't think it's available in Canada
yet do you know what he's talking about
with this Vic victorza so so that was
basically uh the original somago died
before they you know patented it okay so
so the one that's being used now that my
friend's using and by the way he lost I
think
I think he said uh 20 kilos if I'm not
mistaken so that's close to 50 pounds
anyway he goes on um 45 on uh long term
it makes you insulin desensitized I
wouldn't recommend it if you plan to get
to 100 years old
um then I was asking him if it's worth
uh worth it for a guy like me that you
know might want to lose that last
remaining
um you know bit of belly fat like you
know like uh visceral fat he says it may
take away more muscle than fat which you
were talking about
um this [__] is designed for obese
individuals I don't know too many or any
bodybuilder types that take it uh it's
because they don't understand it and
they're a bunch of bro signs idiots
anyway okay it may be worth a try to try
it for three to four months prior to see
what it's like and still have enough
time to correct possible unwanted
results like losing too much muscle as
fat that's complete nonsense dude that
guy literally listens to Peter attia he
doesn't know what the [__] he's talking
about I mean I don't know who he is and
I don't care but like it's it's not well
he's a guy that I respect so that's why
I'm asking no I mean look and he's
listening to Peter Atia he might be a
genius I mean again it always is like
your your your
um what do you call it your um your Echo
chamber like if you don't actually use
this yourself and he did use it himself
well he hasn't used his appetite but he
used some magnetite some magnetite is
different than sir's appetite I mean
again I've used them both but uh so to
address the first thing he said about
the insulin insensitivity that's
completely patently false yeah there's
one more thing when you've done that
okay but I mean look and you know me I'm
the biggest metformin Promoter on the
planet right like I've written all the
Articles like everybody uses my data
when they want to like debunk metformin
or support metformin
if you're going to use anything that is
going to enhance or I'm sorry suppress
appetite enhanced metabolism you have to
use an insulin mimetic so it's either
metformin or dihydroberin
um metformin is still the the be all
end-all because it's coming from a
pharmaceutical uh you know process and
sterility control versus a supplement
like the hydro berberine which you don't
you can't really trust any supplement
manufacturers because they don't have
any sterility processing control but
dihydroper and if you get a quality
version is close to metformin
um but that's not true about
um it screws up insulin sensitivity and
then look I would even argue that at a
certain age and you and I aren't getting
any younger you don't [__] have any
insulin sensitivity so I mean like what
does it even matter our food is
um poisoned you know everything is
sprayed with chemicals and you know like
Dr J says glyphosphate and atrazine I
mean if you live in the midwest in the
United States or Canada you are
literally being bombarded by poison
every single day everything you eat yeah
covers that in depth in his book in the
podcast so I mean so the reality is is
like you're going to be insulin
insensitive as you age unless you take
matters into your own hands and
obviously The glp-1 Agonist can help
metformin can help the hydro berberine
can help using a growth hormone-inducing
peptide like a morellin or Tessa
morellin or even just you know human
growth hormone to micro dosage itself I
mean all these things are going to help
you I mean I do all these things but
I've like I said I've been using it for
a year and a half
um combined between both I've never been
leaner I've never felt better uh I don't
eat as much food anymore the other thing
is
um I would debate and by the way you
know you can get Dr Rudolph everwine
he's been using some aglotide for seven
years with his patients he has a giant
obesity uh clinic in Miami and he's also
the main hormone optimization doctor for
mhi life which are you know some guys
very close to me that I recommend
there's Geniuses in the space
um you know he's been on uh one-on-one
interviews with me and podcasts where we
debated all these things like okay what
happens when people come off you know
what are the side effects like is there
insulin insensitivity is there you know
down regulation of beta-glucan receptors
and the pancreas and all this and he's
like not in my patients and not in the
studies and most people that have used
these they all report the same thing
again correctly incredible fat loss and
my appetite is reduced permanently
reduced now some people asking this is
an important question they're like okay
well what if I don't want to have a
permanently reduced appetite at what
point can I expect to go back to normal
and again without fail in the hundred
people that I've talked to or
interviewed or just know that have used
in them everyone says the same thing in
about two months after
you go back to kind of you feel normal
as far as your doc your your
um your what do you call it your um your
appetite okay
um and then the last part he gave me
feedback on he said also glp and
monogamous are hard on the kidneys and
liver and again for me like I'm always
tracking my liver values because I've
because of that whole family history on
that totally so glp agonists are not
hard on your organs no I mean again
they're hard on the organs of people who
treat their body like dumpster fires
because if you're not is that where
they're getting the data from because
because that's what doctors are giving
it to like severely exactly right that's
exactly right and that's why I made my
video that I put up two weeks ago about
this it I I actually have a really good
friend who's a doctor he has all the
research he sent me like a whole email
breaking down the patient population
groups for all the research that guys
like Atia and them are using you know
again this talking points and dude
obese diabetic women taking 15
milligrams of this drug dude you people
like us should be taking two point five
milligrams a week these people were
taking 15 milligrams every other day
so again the devil is in the details
that is like an industrial dosage so yes
if there's uh you know gallbladder
issues or you know elevated panels of
course and then again what are they
eating they're not eating clean yeah I
wonder what they want yeah I wonder at
the end of the day if there's already
like a predisposition for
um organ damage from somebody that's
morbidly obese because they've done so
much damage to their body like you could
lose 100 pounds of fat right but you've
lost the fat okay good you've probably
saved yourself
some cardiovascular damage or maybe gain
a little bit of longevity but if you've
done damage to your organs we're we're
diabetic when you're overweight then
that could be problematic so
um I'll let you guys do your own
research but how now you've got a book
on peptides do people get the guidance
on how to use peptides from the book is
it provided from Limitless peptides
Linked In the description like how do
they know how to dose it if they want to
try this like how does that work
published I think uh I think it was like
actually physically available to human
beings on February 2nd or 3rd whatever
the fir no it was actually I think
what's it called whatever
it's called Uh optimize your help with
therapeutic peptides and it's on Amazon
yeah let me just grab a link and I'll
drop that yeah no problem
um it was Feb it was exactly February
1st so we pre-launched it uh you know
like the week before in January we
launched it you know it was number one
selling book in men's health alternative
medical like four categories in Europe
uh Canada USA Australia for the entire
month of February it's doctor's pleasure
Health with therapeutic peptides yeah
it's done very well yeah it's got a very
good rating actually it's got a lot of
ratings of course it's a five-star rated
book
um and it's got a lot of Science in it
it's not a book though that is written
for doctors I mean it I mean it is from
a resource perspective but I don't have
I was gonna ask you can anybody read it
and use it absolutely it's written for
it's it's a six I would say a sixth to
eighth grade level uh for anyone who's
interested in using peptides to extend
their life that's okay bottom line I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full-length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out